foreign
ER is with us Jennifer is in
Indianapolis hi Jennifer welcome to the
Ramsay show
hello
hi what's up
um I have a question so my husband and I
um our own two small businesses we that
we each that's our daytime jobs and
um I'm starting a third one but we're
really struggling with budgeting for
those businesses because they are not
consistent income every month and so
knowing how to budget and our expenses
um
there are there isn't much personal
expenses because we are debt free other
than our property
um and so I'm just struggling of how to
get started and how to plan
um with the inconsistent income
and is this question more Jennifer for
the businesses how to budget for those
specific small businesses or the money
you're bringing into your household
budget
um really for all of them but specific
more specifically the businesses okay
and are you and your husband are the is
this the only type of work you guys do
are these two businesses that you're
running
um yes and I'm starting a third one that
is
um
[Applause]
I want to transition from my current
role and I have discovered that there
are no resources and so I would like to
fill a need for my current position and
step out of that and work into
um this this other business
okay I'll let you handle the business
side I can do the I can help you with
the household budget though so when you
so Jennifer for you guys you and your
husband y'all need to create if you
haven't already obviously a pretty
detailed budget for your household and
like you said there's not many bills
that have to pay because you guys are
debt free you just have your property
your home that you owe money on
um so so we always talk about
prioritizing so it's giving first and
making sure your four walls are covered
food shelter utility transportation and
then everything else underneath is
prioritized line item Wise by what's
most important and so for some months
for you guys if it's less than what
you're bringing in then you're gonna say
okay we're gonna have to cut you know
the the bottom three line items in the
budget or or lower some of the amounts
throughout the budget so you kind of
have a plan for the lower months and
then when you guys have high months yes
go and enjoy some of that but also keep
some of that aside so on the low months
you can even pull from that fund as well
so it's a little bit of kind of
gymnastics throughout it but having that
in place having a prioritized budget is
really important and then a fund to be
able to say we can pull from some of
this money that's not an emergency fund
but just for those lower months to do
what we need to do so that's kind of on
the household side but I think Dave's a
little product okay the business that
you're running now what do you make yeah
I make a hundred thousand dollars a year
for mine profit
yes and you want to start another
business
why
um so I'm a behavior consultant and
um as I'm an independent contractor and
I have noticed a need and I have
um
in the business that I do and so I'm
looking to start something else that I
would hopefully transition out of the
independent Contracting than into this
other
um
the business
okay so you're not in business you're
just an independent contractor
correct uh yeah about being in business
you just mean you're 10.99 you don't
operate a business with a with it with
business expenses associated with it you
don't have employees you don't have uh
products you simply work for someone on
contract
yes sir and you're calling that being in
business okay I got you and and you
don't want to do that anymore you want
to do something else
correct and what is it you want to do
um I would like to
um have a subscription-based website
doing what
um
providing materials for people in that
are currently independent contractors
to help kind of supplement the work that
they're doing because as an independent
contractor you've realized oh gosh I
wish I had this and a lot of people need
that so I could
yes step in that space okay okay I want
you to just work on that at night
that's what I'm currently just as a sad
thing
yeah that right now is worth zero and
the other's worth 100K so
um you know you're not going to
transition out of that anytime soon
to get you to get your subscription up
to 100K and you get to quit doing your
day job uh as a contractors it's going
to be a while okay so let's just keep
with that now why is your hundred
thousand Here regular
um it's um each month I um turn in
billable hours and so uh depending on
schedules and things like that what's
your worst month very what's your lowest
month
um eight grand yeah and and you said you
make a hundred grand
eight grand is a hundred grand
8 300 a month is a hundred thousand
okay so then my higher months um can be
upwards of 10
um okay so your your variability is not
that much you could lay out a budget
easily on eight grand and then just do
minor adjustments about a month what's
your husband make
around 160. yeah so you have a 260 000
income to work with and then you can
adjust a little bit off of that so you
don't have a lot of variability a lot of
volatility in your income
um not so much in mine um in my
husband's it's more seasonal work
um and yeah but you can you can
anticipate that I mean you can look up
and go because we're not doing a budget
for for November right now we're doing a
budget for July right now or August
okay and he know he knows right now what
August is going to look like
um yeah pretty close pretty close yeah
yeah you're look you you don't you guys
don't go to zero you're making a quarter
of a million dollars a year okay you
don't go to zero so you make enough
money to run a budget on 20 000 bucks a
month 15 20. and the inconsistent yeah
they make the adjustments on the
overages or the hundreds yeah that and
you know you guys just may be able to
live on way less than that is what's
going to adjust it's just how much you
save per month right exactly it may get
to that point too so yeah you guys are
doing great Jennifer I mean you guys are
making money serious money and I and I
appreciate the you know the
intentionality around the budget because
I think for some people when they when
they are independent contractors or
they're doing freelance work or there is
this inconsistent income a lot of people
just write off a budget and say well I
can't do a budget because I don't have a
consistent income so I think the
question is is really good but you guys
aren't in dire you know you should be
fine even on your low month you have a
very consistent 15 to 17 000 a month
very consistent that you could easily do
the budget on that part and I think your
side gig Jennifer is awesome
I know friends in a field similar to
what you're talking about so anything
that can help them you see a need that's
when businesses and your passion really
do help so I encourage the yeah the work
at nights and weekends of doing that so
that's exciting absolutely this thing
started on a nights and Weekend Deal